الان ننتقل الى الحليف الاخر لروسيا الهند
التي تتراس هذا العام قمه مجموعه العشرين
نقلت عن سته مسؤولين بارزين في الحكومه
الهنديه قولهم ان بلادهم لا تريد ان تناقش
مجموعه العشرين فرض مزيدا من العقوبات على
روسيا احد المسؤولين الذين تحدثت معهم
الوكاله قال ان الهند غير معنيه بمناقشه
او دعم اي عقوبات اضافيه وان العقوبات
القائمه حاليا على روسيا لها اثر سلبي على
العالم بحسب وصفه تحدثت نيودلهي عن ان
اجتماع وزراء ماليه ومحافظي البنوك
المركزيه لدول مجموعه العشرين سيبحث اثر
الحرب على الاقتصاد الكلي بشكل عام اليوم
اعادت الهند تاكيد اعاده تاكيد موقفها من
الحرب في اوكرانيا بالدعوه لسلوك طريق
الدبلوماسيه وحتى يومنا هذا تلتزم الهند
بالحياد في هذه الازمه واحجمت عن ادانه
روسيا وفي جانب اخر زادت مشترياتها من
النفط الروسي على مدار العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
هذه الحقبه ليست وقتا للحرب فالديمقراطيه
والحوار والدبلوماسيه هي سبل المضي قدما
في بدايه الملف قلنا قلنا علاقات مثلث
روسيا الهند الصين مختلفه بين دوله واخرى
والحلقه الاضعف هي علاقه الصين والهند
وزير الخارجيه الهندي سوبرمان جيشنكار قال
في مقابله تلفزيونيه ان علاقات بلاده جيده
مع القوى العالميه الكبرى بما في ذلك
روسيا ولكن ليس مع الصين جيشانكار اكد ان
العلاقه مع روسيا مستقره جدا رغم
الاضطرابات المتعلقه بحرب اوكرانيا بينما
علاقه نيودلهي مع بكين على النقيض نظرا
لانتهاك الصين اتفاقيه اداره الحدود مع
الهند وبسبب نشرها قوات في المنطقه
الحدوديه المتنازع عليها